these are three of the most intense
moments in Joe Rogan history starting
off with his controversial episode with
Steven Crowder where a discussion about
marijuana escalated into a heated verbal
Exchange in fact Stephen Crowder has
never returned to The Joe Rogan
Experience hold on stop no no way too
much
no no no no I don't talk in paragraphs I
make full points then there was Adam
Conover who came in hot without landish
claims about women's sports and trans
youth but was completely unprepared for
any pushback from Joe which ultimately
led to Rogan mopping the floor with
Conover and his attempt at virtue
signaling on Joe's show most of the
games that we've constructed are
actually sort of biased towards a male
type of body right that sounds
ridiculous and who could forget the
legendary moment with Jamie killstein
whose strong stance on sexual assault
being worse than murder led to an
all-time undressing from Joe
foreign
thank you